this is pretty simple it starts so
simple and it will progressively get
more tricky by the way each of these
features to show you how they work I
will pull out different functions to
show you because for example as you'll
notice this graph will graphs for
example can only have a horizontal or
oblique asymptote you can't have both
and you'll see why shortly okay so I'm
going to give you a whole bunch of
examples so that you see the different
features inhale how you identify them
okay so to begin with symmetry have a
look at this function y equals x plus 1
on X does it have any kind of symmetry
mmm any takers what do you think yeah
what do you recommend you think it's odd
why might we think that it's odd okay so
remember what the definitions of odd and
even functions are which are like this
so here's even symmetry even is if you
put in a negative value right it doesn't
matter what you get back is the same as
if you put in positive values
okay so x squared that's a typical even
function right an odd function is almost
identical except when you put in the
negative value what do you get out the
other area yeah you're going to get the
flipped version of that okay so the
easiest way to test this out is to say
well okay if I put in if I define this
in this way right using function
notation okay what happens when I put in
a negative like so every R I see an X
I'm going to replace it with a negative
x okay am I going to get I'm going to
get minus X plus 1 on minus X that makes
sense now what I'm looking for is either
one of these I'm looking for either one
of these happening okay in order to see
whether the first one happens is like is
this exactly the same as this and the
answer is no so it's more even okay now
is this equal to negative of that right
and just to make it super obvious I'm
going to take
that negative as a factor right so
you're going to get X plus one on X so
it's odd see that that's minus f of X
another way that you could see it is
this idea of putting things in one
fashion is very very important so it's
helpful as well one if I were to combine
these two components into one fraction
right what would I get on the numerator
I have X square plus 1 on X okay when
you're looking for or even century you
need to pay because all of these things
are to break you need to make close
attention to the powers and where you
get odd or even powers did that get
alluded to on Friday yeah okay so you
can see up here right when you put your
negative x in there right because it's
squared what happens to that negative it
becomes um disregarded basically okay
because you square it out so the
negative disappears then you just get
that negative on the bottom right so
when you put it in this form I think
it's kind of more obvious that what
you're going to get is an odd function
okay the sign disappears from here and
then you get it down here so of course
you're going to get negative f of X okay
so so far so good
we've identified a form of symmetry so
it's an odd function so as I start to UM
put this in here everything that I now
get I'm just going to do one half of the
graph okay and once I do one half I will
get everything on the left-hand side
okay well or vice-versa factorize have a
look at it is it factorized there it is
there it's in one fraction yeah as I put
in one fraction that's it there's
there's nothing you can do to that
there's no way you can factorize x
squared plus one you could factorize a
difference of squares but you cannot
factorize the sum of squares so because
this is a very simple one I'm done there
now let's have a look at these
asymptotes okay we start with verdict
ones because they're easy where do you
get the very class and turn front bless
you where do you see yeah minted okay we
look at the denominator right vertical
asymptotes
are about the domain right for their the
flipside of the domain right there the
restriction and restrictions come from
the denominator if you make the
denominator equal to zero you will find
the equations of all the vertical
asymptotes that you have no matter how
many there are so if what we had down
here was like X plus 1 times X plus 2
times X plus 3 and so on right if you
let that denominator equal zero you
solve it you'll get x equals minus 1 and
x equals -2 and x equal mastery however
many you have and those will be all your
vertical asymptotes in this case I just
have the one right so let's draw him in
don't forget it's important to put the
equation on of all your asymptotes as
you'll see you get quite a few flying
around eventually
we've got a vertical one now horizontal
and oblique asymptotes just hand up
quickly
who's met horizontally asymptotes before
ok excellent so about half a year right
so let's do it this way vertical
asymptotes are about where your graph
does it doesn't exist more so it doesn't
okay horizontal and oblique asymptotes
are about something quite different
they're about how the graph is behaving
at its extremities that's a really
important word how the graph is behaving
its extremities okay in other words as
and I'm going to introduce a bit of
notation here it's very very common
sense but it will be important for us
later as X approaches that's what the
error means as X approaches positive and
negative infinity what is the whole
function doing ok as X approaches
positive or negative infinity what is
the whole function doing okay now before
I get to this one right let's just think
about a simple example the one that I
put up before if I said
come back to this guy because you're so
familiar with you right as X approaches
infinity for this as well
okay what's happening - why what's
happening to what what value is it going
toward yeah it's going towards zero
right now not only is it going towards
zero but I'm going to add in a little
bit of extra notation here okay in a
second it's approaching zero but it's
approaching it from a particular
direction right which way is it coming
from is it coming from the top or coming
from the bottom it's coming from as I go
towards positive infinity right I'm
coming from the top like you have the
picture in your head don't you there it
is right look over here that's that's
positive infinity coming over this side
right and I'll get in closer and closer
but I'm coming from the top it has to
because I've got a positive number in
the numerator and a positive very very
positive number on the denominator you
take the ratio you get a positive okay
so the way that we indicate this is in
notation right is not just a frickin
zero it is but it's approaching zero
from above that's a bit of a weird form
a notation you're like zero positive
like zero doesn't have a sign that's
true what this means is where are you
coming from to get to zero okay does
that make sense means you had a question
okay sure so now that's just one of the
extremities that's just one of the
extremities right there's another one
which happens at the opposite end of the
spectrum okay and what's happening is as
you put very very large negative numbers
in wrong way large negative numbers in
okay Y is still approaching zero but
it's approaching from below zero right
it's going to be minus 0.1 and minus
0.01 and so on so zero with a minus sign
okay so here are two little bits of
weird notation which I you don't need
for this upcoming assessment but it's
just the most efficient way to talk
about what's happening
so you can work out what's happening to
a graph asymptotically addiction is by
testing out values like you can put in x
equals a hundred and a thousand and a
million and so on and see what happens
to your graph okay so now that we
understand basically what these are
about how do you work out whether it's
horizontal or oblique how for instance
can I see just by looking at it doing
the computation I see that there's an
oblique asymptote for this graph what
kinds of features are we looking for yes
yeah sure so we don't horizontal this
right result all just go in approaching
a number a constant just like this it
doesn't have to be 0 by the way it could
be approaching 1 or 3 or minus 50 okay
so long as it's a non bar and oblique
asymptote is off at an angle right so
it's not just a constant it's going to
be and you'll see in a second it's going
to be approaching a life that's
increasing or decreasing rather than
just horizontal okay so the way I think
about it is not horizontal